all right here's the first story we got
grand jury indicts Daniel penny in
Chokehold death of Jordan Neely Neely's
death was ruled a homicide according to
the medical examiner they say the exact
charges will not be unsealed until Penny
appears in court at a later date the
sources said Penny was initially
arrested on second-degree manslaughter
charge okay so to clarify the uh I I
thought they had indicted him for that
reason so we don't know exactly what he
was indicted for but he was arrested for
a second degree manslaughter video
showed Penny putting kneeling a
Chokehold on May 1st several witnesses
observed nearly making threats assistant
district attorney Joshua steinglass told
the judge some witnesses told police
that Neely was yelling and harassing
passengers on the train Authority said
police source told ABC news that Penny
was not specifically being threatened by
Neely when he intervened and that Neely
had not become violent and had not been
threatening anyone in particular Neely
was homeless at the time of the incident
so there is another witness on the train
who said that he was threatening all of
their lives saying he was going to
seriously hurt them and that she thought
they were in serious danger and that
Penny saved their life lives but this is
what's happening in big cities so it's
unsurprising to hear that they've
actually issued this indictment the fact
they arrested him in the first place I
have questions about these police
officers I have questions about
you know where this where this country
goes if this is the case we had that
story that we talked about and we'll get
into more detail with San Francisco's
downtown district being totally
obliterated and I want to show you this
tweet this is a tweet from Ellen Barkin
Ellen Barkin um I'm not familiar with
you know what her career is I think
she's a writer or something but she just
responded good
so you have people who live in New York
who every day are facing serious threats
of violence as the city is Rife with
crime
I Google searched and I hate to be a
little crass but I Google searched rape
on a New York a Subway
if you Google search that you will see a
ridiculous amount of stories almost
every week something like that happens
it is shocking to me that there are
women in New York City with all of that
going on every single week and they're
celebrating the fact that someone tried
to help people to save people from a
violent dangerous individual
well I mean none of these people have
any ability to look more than five
seconds into the future and their
General world view is
if something makes me feel positive
happy emotions it's good if something
makes me feel negative sad emotions it's
bad and so hearing about somebody
intervening and saving other people's
lives potentially but knowing that that
cost the aggressor their life might make
somebody feel negative in the immediate
short term and so then they're going to
try to find a rationalization for that
negative emotion because they don't want
to challenge it they just want to stick
with what they feel and similarly when
you have these stories of people being
harmed of course you've mentioned this
before Tim that there are people who are
pushed in front of the subway this never
becomes a story right when there's
completely senseless violence or when a
woman is sexually abused in public it
doesn't make headlines the same way that
a man defending citizens does and that's
for a very simple reason because the
media wants us to know that if we stand
up for ourselves against violent
criminals we will be punished for it I
mean this is by Design they want
criminals to overrun the cities they
want to make life as untenable as
possible because this is something
Marxist virtually always do when they're
trying to upset the social order make
things as unstable for people as
possible
just generally make cities unlivable I
suppose it's like the ice cream shop in
Seattle that's suing now because their
business suffered a loss of Revenue when
the autonomous Zone the Capitol Hill
autonomous Zone Chas was established but
the same ice cream shop was calling for
them to defund the police that's right
yeah that was that was a good headline
ice cream shop that supported to funding
police is now suing the city because the
police didn't help him it seems like as
I often say it's a chaotic and
destructive force that is its intention
is just to destroy it I I can't I can't
put myself in the shoes of these voters
of people in New York City people like
Ellen Barkin who are like I'm glad
that people are stopped are not allowed
to defend themselves it's like Bizarro
America you know it's like it's like
intentionally nonsensical illogical and
destructive but yeah what the left has
effectively done is it's gotten people
to cheer for the prospect of
defenselessness right so we're going to
defund the police and then we're also
going to prosecute you when you defend
yourself and we're going to do
everything we possibly can to ensure
it's as difficult as possible if not
impossible for you to get a firearm to
protect yourself or your family and we
know whenever the left is in control of
of anything things don't get better for
people I think one really hilarious
example of this was the Capitol Hill
occupied protest or autonomous Zone
depending on how you want to refer to it
where leftist literally took over
several city blocks in Seattle and not
only did no one in the media call it an
Insurrection but ironically enough this
was done in order to protest police
violence
and then over the course of this being
set up two teenagers were shot in this
autonomous Zone that they set up so
they'll try to pursue these insane
utopian Solutions without actually
knowing anything when they're trying to
implement you know these Solutions
without actually doing anything that's
going to improve life for people but
just trying to shirk off the authority
that's already there and then when
people get get hurt they're never held
to account for it because they had good
intentions and what else matters when I
used to talk about the escalation of
conflict in this country and the risk of
Civil War 2017 there's an article in uh
New Yorker I I went back over that
article today because we just saw the
president federally indicted by I'm
sorry the former president uh future
president perhaps uh very likely we saw
Donald Trump indicted federally by Joe
Biden so this is a president targeting
his polit his political rival
that's the highest level
that's it what I was saying back then
was all of these conflicts that we're
seeing this political conflict it will
reach higher and higher levels of
politics and I was told that I was crazy
that I was wrong it wasn't going to
happen now what we're seeing and the
reason I bring this up in this context
is the people that are celebrating
a former Marine
trying to save lives celebrating his
criminal indictment arrest and charges
when he was trying to protect people is
it's it it seems
like opposite day it seems like an
inversion on American morals and values
it seems like literally Bizarro America
yeah this is what happens when people
are led by their emotions and not logic
when they've given away like you look at
the pictures of this NBC is it NBC or
ABC ABC News article there it shows
Daniel Penny bad guy I mean he's got
handcuffs on he's got five o'clock
like looks got Shadow on his face then
you scroll down and you see the the
other guy though oh yeah homeless guy
look at this glamor picture like this is
the guy that was screaming he was going
to kill people on the subway uh but man
you're not gonna know that by looking at
that beautiful picture of him with all
that really nice lighting and the city
in the background
um so I think what happened is this guy
walked on the train I was like I'm gonna
kill so and but he wasn't specifically
targeting any one person and that's the
that's the argument they're making but
he was obviously yelling and making
people uncoverable enough that people
felt like they had to intervene
apparently stop this guy before he
started apparently they all went to like
one side to avoid him like he was
threatening that isn't common maybe not
commonly New York Behavior but that is
like if you have ridden a New York
Subway you know when the guy starts
screaming that smells like poop down the
way you get up and you move otherwise
he's gonna come sit on you
well these are people who say that words
are violence and misgendering somebody
is incitement and then this guy is
screaming that he's not afraid to go
back to jail and he'll kill somebody so
and there was no need for anyone to step
in and neutralize that threat it's it's
patently ridiculous on its face and
you're right Ian they're showing uh
they're showing nice looking pictures of
the person who was an aggressor and
they're showing pictures that make the
defendant in this case look as unlikable
as possible every single time there's a
story of a police officer shooting
somebody in the news the media has this
Unwritten rule never show the mug shot
never show a picture of this person in
police custody always show them when
they were younger always show them in
their most attractive moment and then
this guy's on trial and of course they
have to represent him as uh some kind of
violent maniac and not someone who did
something reasonable and tried to help
people so they're showing you pictures
where he doesn't look at it it's they
they show a photo of Penny In Handcuffs
looking at scowling right they show the
perpetrator the the person who who was
the aggressor with a glamor shot in City
Lights it's probably 10 years old too
yeah absolutely my question now I'm
sorry this once so this yeah
it feels intentional it is it feels like
the media intentionally wants to gut and
rip apart and Destroy and the legal
system is playing the lap dog of the
media whether it wants to or not like
they don't want their careers to be
ruined I bet Daniel Penny's lawyer was
like don't say anything in public about
it but I'm wondering if you'll post it a
video Daniel Penny did yes he I haven't
seen it yet was it an emotional plea
because if he hasn't captured people's
emotions yet I feel like he's doomed to
the legal system but if he can get out
ahead of it and start making internet
videos nope then maybe like the guy
sorry there's questions about whether or
not people in New York on a jury will
actually convict him because they're
probably going to be like there will be
regular people saying I experience this
no way we can't config this guy but I
have a feeling that after a few of the
uh riots and antifa smashing windows and
setting fires after a couple of those
then the jury will go in under armed
protection and just say I just want to
be left alone I'll do whatever you say
yep
yep I mean there's a question that the
United States has to ask itself um and
I'm taking this from a conversation that
I I had on my podcast the other day and
it actually didn't uh come from my guest
it came from him paraphrasing a book
that he'd read recently which
unfortunately I don't remember the name
of but you you really have to ask
yourself the question who are you
rooting for right and whenever you look
at these stories whenever you analyze
anything the media is talking about
whenever you're looking at a public
policy prescription you have to ask who
is this rooting for who is this helping
who do we care about thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8 pm and become a member over
at timcast.com for uncensored members
only shows exclusive thanks for hanging
out and we'll see you all next time